when that water comes in it changes
everything
it just kept dumping rain for hours and
for days
it was heart-wrenching
it rose overnight very quickly it's
pretty mind-boggling in more ways than
one
it's a pretty emotional moment to say
the least
people are worried about their families
and their loved ones and so i started
thinking about how can i help with this
the office of emergency management is
calling on owners of any powered
watercraft in greater houston to assist
in the rescue of those trapped in
flooded areas
when we woke up that morning we
discovered that we are an island all the
major highways all the major roadways
were underwater the only way we could
talk to each other was mainly through
social media and so we created a
facebook group called the fairfield
relief effort
my brother actually saw something on
facebook saying that we need all the
help we can get any flat bottom boat or
shallow water boat that can come assist
we just kind of looked at each other and
the rest is history we got home and
loaded up the boat and headed up that
way
there was a line of people just wanting
to give to either go do rescues and
donate anything to help the others it
was so overwhelming the amount of people
wanting to support us we had well over
200 plus volunteers and we rescued over
125 people
we got in touch with delmar and you know
we asked is there anything we can do do
you need help or anything like that
he took him back to his house and he was
able to save a few things austin came up
here and helped me pick everything up
they are examples to everybody in this
county they take helping people to a new
level
our son's kindergarten teacher she
posted online that her in-laws needed to
be rescued that their neighborhood was
flooding really fast and they needed
somebody to come down and get them
krisha right away messaged me and then
they went and rescued my in-laws
my particular vehicle has a snorkel on
it so it's able to go into waters a
little deeper than normal
there were road closures everywhere and
their neighborhood was completely
underwater
to get from point a to point b we're
navigating around people in canoes and
boats
when we finally got the family back here
to dry ground if you will miss brew and
she says thank you how can we repay you
it's like listen you taught my kid how
to read it's fine
we're good
houston is such an incredibly large city
with so many people from various
backgrounds but it didn't matter people
came together to help each other i was
in constant awe of my neighbors of my
entire community i just got chills now
when people are in need it's just an
instinct that kicks in i was just one
small part of a community
everybody pitched in i mean it was a
group effort and i've grown up in texas
so i know what people are like here and
they're pretty awesome we're pretty good
at taking care of each other
[Music]
you